people you know they worry they're so
worried about going viral
but to be honest it's really they they
need to worry about finding that niche
you know find that niche find out
what you like to do and not what the
people like
that's what they gravitate towards the
authenticity yeah yeah cause a lot of
your videos
that you thought were gonna go viral it
don't it's the opposite right
i'm telling my bro it's so crazy and now
i'll be at a poem like i just when i
post the i mean of course i wanted to do
good
but it's not to me it's up to the people
it's what the people like but i it's
like i don't
done a few things to know
what they like so that's kind of an
advantage that i do kind of have
but you gotta keep going to like really
find that niche though
you know so when did you feel like was
it was it a repost
or like what what took you from okay i'm
being consistent i'm hammering it out
until you're like
oh i found it when i thought when i like
when i said when i started doing stuff
with
other people like beasts of my own and
candace and that's when it took off i
started to see
like the team yeah you know what i'm
saying that's how i say i couldn't do i
can't
to that level it's like you can't do it
by yourself
you know i mean i'm naturally funny you
know
but once you found that team and it's
like you find
yourself you find a lot of stuff that's
you know it's
it's like you find the thing that god
got for you you know what i'm saying so
no mo dick there you go i'm walking to
my calling no more
no more you know so yeah man
yeah that took off yeah that's you know
and so crazy
when i said that it just came to my mind
it's just improv it was improv yeah that
whole thing was improv
oh wow yeah yeah i think we set an idea
like we want to do
and she came in already you know you
know i just something she clicked in my
house like
no more day and it's so crazy it's so
crazy because in my mind
it's like don't say that say that and it
kept going
you know no more dick no more
is
and i'm like okay cool and before i
pause you know
i'm like it's gonna be funny i don't
know if it's gonna be funny or not you
know what i'm saying
dog posted it yo it was crazy i had like
but we had probably had like two to
three hundred comments in like
six minutes and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah 50 cent jumped on two yeah
yeah he um he reposted it he reported
another um video that we did as well
but yeah you know and
this is it was crazy bro i was just like
and that's been like a thing like every
time somebody see me now they might be
like no more dick
there's no
stuff like that that people don't
it's like you don't write those things
down you can't write that down right
those moments like you know even like
with martin
i i feel like you know some of his stuff
was improper like for example like you
know with jerome jerome and
i say he didn't i'm pretty sure he
didn't write that it was just a
character
yeah it's just character you know what
i'm saying yeah the stuff like that that
sticks
i don't think you can write those things
you can't write that stuff man it's just
meant to be
it's just me it's just guys you know
it's just natural bro so
thanks for watching hot breath the verse
if you want to support the show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive in the algorithm